Lock it in okay bitter lot, and you're locked in with me
hai\
lol
wut
Hopefully, they all drop it like the chinky or something
We're going right now. They're jumping yellow John just look at the bow my God
y
at all three two one go
i beleive i can fly
Straight down
weeeee
They wouldn't follow us
Maybe I heard I heard more voices
coming in
You guys see the l-shaped building yeah yeah, yeah, yeah right there all that all those fillings everyone take a building okay?
Hey, it's peaceful
Yes, I don't see any zombies just for 1/2 hour southeast pretty close. No we've three with us. Oh
Above us. Oh shit you get a gun quickly wow okay quick, okay?
I see guns on the front porch here right outside. There's tons of them ah fucking goddamn it goddamn it goddamn it goddamn
Oh my God. Oh my god. Oh my God. Oh, no oh my God
Oh my God, if someone can't help you I have someone punch me move it right up the roof. Oh boy
I am there's one at the fountain. I'm coming towards you mark. You're right
Yeah, behind me. There's one more
I'm fucking down
That one's really low weight that one's really low these are all down. I'll get you up. I can get you up Jack
Freeman Super short now
There's one more in the grass there that is that all three of them?
Yeah, I think that might be everyone just keep an eye out keep an eye out keep an eye out it was fucking two in
my house
Jesus Christ
Okay, holy shit all right wow kicked it together stick together, and I'm with mark Morgan. I restore nick I go yeah
Word of warning the M16 is only bursts and single. Yeah, do you want the
M416 or whatever it is that yeah?
S has full auto the M416 of this car is the best one marquez low one hummer. Yeah, I'm on greta discography
I need a backpack first because I'm all full up, okay there was one of the second story. I level two
I believe okay cool. I see it. Oh it was move
Okay, then you run low on health
Yes, or no only one sticks over here if anyone needs
That still okay seventy two four times
No, they don't want a weighed backpack level two in here. So get to the left. Oh, I don't need bold leadership
I have no attachments for my scarf. We find any attachments for a star
Okay, do you have I got a an M16 an s?
1897 so pretty pretty weak, but all the quickness right now. I've got a hollows. I've got two hollow sites
I'm dropping down here people want to upgrade their site. There's a zombie in her compound here in
Southwest
behind the yellow house
They just ran around the left corner the LmO right I come and finish them off. Yeah, the right side we go lift
I'll stand back in just in case you guys get flying for something I see you
She's almost dead right by you didn't wake up
Nice, you done. Yes officer. Oh, no, Brinnin
Not grinning he dead young, Indiana crossbow. Just love with you, and oh my God. I want a crossbow so hard
Yeah
Don't get too spread out get out guys. I'm just gonna check this house outside, but I'm arthur his wait
Can you come with me there should be pistols. Can you come with me wade yeah? I'm not sitting a pistol I seen today
Why I'm enough pistols. Did anyone try to dig a hope in two-story the register epsilon muscle Mark, and I started it
Yeah, okay, wait. There's pistols in there
That's a blue. Okay. I would I'll be a grab one just so I have another gun, okay?
What guns do everyone have I've got a shotgun and wait? There's a pistol right here, man
I got one okay, alright heading back downstairs that were your above Jack and I are downstairs. Yeah, no one outside that I can see
We're actually right on the edge of the circle too. Which is nice yeah, we want anyone have a foregrip for a scar no
Okay, we could check this other out house outside the compound this one on the hill. I mean sighs
alright huge difference
All right, I'm with Jack over here. So we'll search this building who this doors open. Yeah, I thought mark was yeah
Yeah, no door ready. All right. Well you guys find a foregrip. Let me know. I'm with Jack just so we're not split up
Yeah, I'm not gonna watch marks back. Yeah saying we want to be heading to poaching key or school
I think they only exampled at school. They think they all went to school. Yeah
Yeah, but chinky is where as the circle an island all right? We're clear here. That's all there's another day. Good in here
They're pretty all right. Let's head back to them. Oh wait. I'm a good this one more frag, okay
Yeah, I'm full I could literally can't carry anything. So we're heading to blue
Okay, we're followed. We're behind you guys. We should keep moving we can only build one for
Three oh we had
97 I think when we came in so unless some dropped out we killed more yeah, we killed a good number
oss all has five or six maybe
Yeah, I went there for a lot of it. So I kind of missed out
I saw one jumper off the robber ahead of us at 2:10
Which would come left and get it's actually come out it on the ground sitting there already. It's not even smoking any well
Watch.watch approaching it for zombies camping it
I'm moving
It's a like that box in right there in the opening weights running right for it watch watch out for four campers around it
Just make sure approach slowly and have your shotgun party and then
Really? It's if it's not like an M249 or like a tommy gun. I don't even think we want it at this point it is
An adrenaline shot from Eleven three backpack on them two four nine
Shits on so now now. Go to blue
Yeah, yeah, I don't know you any movement up in lace. I've been watching like Shaq
You're getting left find all the way for you
Yeah, I mean just go new circle if you want like a hollow side
I've got one you can have for that thing no. No. I just got one dope movement ahead, maybe
I can't tell from the flies around here. I keep thinking yeah zombies
sometimes bit stains on my monitor from screaming
like the life of Allah here
Oh my God
Well, even I have that which
Surprises me because I do not scream like my level three backpack out here on one of those more than you think you do I
Really need a level three bag if anyone else doesn't need them go ahead. There's an eight right here
I can't pick up this grenade, but somebody else should grab everyone doing on med Kits and
I'm good. It gets three energy drinks. That's not bad
Yeah, I'm good on the there's some bandages on my crap one of these nevermind. I can't grab any advantages well
I don't know the well time to use bandages anyway, but advantages there. Yeah, I feel like you might as well
Just hold it out. Oh, there's like an ass. Load of first aid kits in here
Five five spice ammo
Galore today a little three helmet on me. Oh I need that somehow. I don't have a helmet oh
I only have a little one helmet so nicely helmet on me as well
Go over to here. Oh
Mark baby toe I'm sorry. I'm sorry. There's level twos though. There's two level to each right here. I'm good
I'll shit
I'm gonna shit on the sites down here as well quick draw for an ar and S12
I've got a quick job prefer to fund an extended man. I do need a
tactical
For grip not a technical for grade. Oh yeah. Oh dear boy. It's not me inside, ooh
Nice dead head. I can't so I thought I heard two voices though. Yep, I did
All right, I'm out there
Research they're walking
How dare they try to eat your eyes?
All right
I'm falling up right behind you yeah, I'm just baiting a little bit. They probably got spooked away
don't push too far out today in a pTerosaur, okay, I've
366 M249 mo
There's more five five six right here's anyone have any way what ammo does V2 495 five six yeah?
Exactly, okay sixty rounds right here, and I need that or I don't I wait. Yes, no
Mmm, okay, I'm dropping my
762 Ammo for that if someone needs a seven six - oh Jack Jack 760 right here, okay?
There's guys there's two more level three helmets right here. Oh
And there's one up on top. Oh jack. Don't forget. I'm standing you go over and walk up the ramp. Yeah, all right
I think we're pretty much fully loaded guys. We should just get in the circle and start to find the next place
We're going to spend some time I see no business today they gotta be out of there. They reduced damage
I don't know how much but they do reduce damage
well
That's the thing the norm of G rules don't really apply anymore if you were if you were naked
And you just took a punch from Azam azam be with maxed out damaged Melee damage it to the face
You would be down in one shot. Oh
So the fact that we weren't getting one shot
It well in the last couple rounds when they were coming up and scooping us means that it was reducing the damage by some amel
I think that level prevents been a big different things it took them like six or seven
Yeah, drop the wrecking it's out west. I'm gonna come with you. Oh, that's a little ways away though, man. I
Mean where's our one concert archive in the building next to you, okay?
I just exited the building so I'm gonna watch you. We'll wait out your voice. I
Don't have voice on so maybe not what about that think other gis or I'm going for Jackie's alone
So I think the chinky is where we're in so
Everyone is underway. I'm so scared for to see the horde
I know I wish I wish I had some sense of where they are cuz you know somewhere, though a bunch of them gone
So many of them to the Northwest 300. Oh no, they're all on that ridge right there? Oh no. Oh, that's
obviously clover them that
You think they saw?
I just want to hear like
A big old zombie roar, I don't know I don't want to hear any of that. I want to go home
I wish that there was more violence
I wish they could like take down structures, and so you could be like in a building and it was just like
You're like the house is going to collapse like you that that would that would not that this needs more terror
But that would be fucking terror
There's a destructible Shack can they push them down yeah, but why the hell would you go there are doors on them?
So it's like there's no reason for them to do that. They could just walk around and kill the shit out of you
I mean, I'm just we have to go in italy try to spot them you'll we're late
You'll never see the whole evening hired Mrs.. Slipped away
Ha ha ha yeah, I'm pretty I any adrenaline
I have in my body is being used up for this flippin recourse agreement or waiting for them to like
Just pop up out of the grass as we run by and be like oh
I got ya I don't want that to happen either we need to
Send that herds are we going to blue or just a vehicle right here if we need this
well there is
Cool. It's a jeep yeah
We might actually want that just as a way to get the fuck out of
Place on this with more of this building another blown open by bombs or punched open at some point. Well go ahead then oh
no, wheel oh
oh
Hey, Jerr izing fuck you are right zombies. Why oh?
It always filled up and guards are really
Uncomfortable no back ourselves into a corner from which there's no escape hell. Yeah good. God. I think there's narration everyone
What an energy drink I don't think I could take it, but I'll try. I don't know
Mark need something. I'm just gonna take puppy's painkillers
Just take it. Take the energy drink and then you'll be fully stocked okay. Where was I no? I'm gonna pay on the table
Bye jack yeah, it's not the take up Africa fuck it. I could take a break or time yeah
It's in it's right there. No still a man right can do for you a circle
Oh, we might as well stay at the edge. We know there were a bunch of them northwest of us
I can't wait to see them come pouring down the hill toward us yep
I don't why what are using your guns on auto, or single shot. I don't single shot
Just just so I can have a little bit of control well you have to say I like the control
But the same time there's like a mass amount of them. Just drop us on a line right at us. Oh, oh well
That's telegraphing unless it drops already, okay?
we Gonna
We have two minutes
I'm not worried about the time. I'm worried about the gemenese they didn't fall out you guys want to follow that road, right?
This is this is a bad place for last end they can come from everywhere
There's a tiny circle in 80 80 80 we let's climb the hill the direction that we saw them on the ridge
We have to fight them at some point wade yeah here over here. Drop right here. All right, okay?
There's a drop of 300 between 300 and northwest oh, I see yeah, all right. I'm just another drop coming
There's no hope and you drop
But at least we can feel comfortable eating is it I'm 1 or 2 go it drops only happen in the white circle
Oh, I don't like going over the top of these hills where we can see what couple this is stress. Oh, no
Oh someone finally bled out that sucks. So when we kill the lot down - long time ago
Just finally died I got a bad feeling about there's too many zombies alive frost ball is buck dark. I know
Nothing makes that Rafi
Bobby Bobby Bobby oh
Well, that's that's the that's the chime
Dinner Bell ding ding gained another wonder who left another one to the left there at the drop right here where I'm facing
Them oh
I know, I'm watching our back. I do not want ya back on the left make sure we watch all directions. We're good
There's one behind you take a direction way to pick a direction, okay?
You keep running into me and looking the same way as me look. I just don't want to say and still get punched from behind
All right, I'll look in this thing real quick. I can't we're safe yeah, Marc magnum
There's an Awm Ghillie suit behind me Bob
Getting giddy, too is good. Oh yeah, somebody could get the Ghillie suit and like become invisible go for it. Oh another one. That's great
Lots of them lots of them guys come up the hill for thoughts contacts come hey Des
There's one where I am
Yeah, we gotta kill it nice and straight killed someone whoops that was not a fad. They're coming up from behind really really fast guys
Yeah, we got done
tagging
oh
Boy, oh boy. Yeah, bailon. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Yeah. I'm very close to death run run run
Come on by - you just run it there
Into the circle I'm down. Oh boy. Yeah, go go to the circle right now. Thank you sir. All right time to go
That's bob ha I'm coming. I've got a lot behind me you have me - I've got a lot in front of me
I've got a lot of them everywhere. Oh
Oh, God mom you're for God. Oh
My God, they're so ever
I'll help I can't help market a product marketing program run
Yeah, Mark's the safest right now so many behind you on the hill ways I could all like us so happy
oh
Boy, go, that's a lot of them hang on. Yeah
It's like six of them all around you I'll bobby. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy
I don't I can't reload I guess I could switch to my other gun
When you guys have eel, so he wins the blues on eurocode. Oh, whoa switched another gun you asshole. Oh boy
Oh going on and he'll
What nailed nailed there don't die immediately come on?
well
Moyna help me oh
They don't have healed where you do. You know what that is. It's in there kill me markiplier
I don't have that ah I don't have there
Is one wait oh hey? Hey?
Cool back get him get him Jenna good. Oh, God damn. I do talk to run. Oh
Yeah, blue Zone is the only thing you oh no hold that right there wait are we going out to play Zone?
Oh, no, oh, I think I just gonna fall randomly. I think y'all got a copycat
oh
Jesus I've been one punch to death yes, the heart will be free so oh
God
You're too good of a talky good